Felix gathered up his courage and
breathe in and breathe out ah lunch to a
bouquet of flowers he and his hand and
messed around with his hair I'm messin
about his decision he thought about his
decision twice and even three times but
there was no turning back this time hmm
he was going to go and fall into an
embrace with Ken I can't wait ah the man
he has felt love towards since the first
day they met all those years ago
Christ PewDiePie Felix exited the car
and went up to the stairs at the house
that belonged to the bearded man what's
up YouTube eautiful beard he knocked on
the door with all his might goddamn it's
a lot of strength how the ones he
doesn't hear you play video games oh my
god is knocking I've been suddenly felt
discouraged that this Nixle listen this
is you now oh yeah I'll be fine
you know what [ __ ] it you go you go I'm
not even there anymore stop it the
Swedish talked to himself and waited for
a response when none came out he figured
he was recording again true so he swung
open the door and that was surprisingly
unlocked he just broke into my house
haha well hey that's why I'm knocked in
the door with all my mind and to his
horror he noticed something he probably
shouldn't have he was happy
no clothes scatter around the wooden
floor and creaking bed noises enacted
from the brute what does that mean that
means there's sound it's happening yeah
always fat naked though so this is true
enacted from the broom across the
hallway Ken with Shelley busy now hey I
can't read my can't do it however
curiosity flared over Felix he processed
within wait with few hesitation towards
the noisy room and noticed two bodies
melted into an
race with each other and intimate
whispers into each other's ears
it was crying kidding Oh what oh yeah
give me some of that beer sugar mmm that
only noticed the visitor next the door
when they heard the bouquet of flowers
fallen into the plate was all into the
flowers as it's been asked in the
bouquet of flowers fall into the flowers
as its petals scattered all around just
like Felix's hopes okay okay okay
ken I thought we had that fake Felix
whispered out I mean every thought we
have a can jump in a bed gathering of a
blanket to cover his nude body my box
Isis cry in the bed with no sheets to
cover him so you lay there naked ears
like hey what's up I don't give a damn
look at my dick yeah this is what you
think I promise I'm had Ken I'm hurt and
hurt was the last emotion Felix Olof
ever experienced wait am I gonna die
outside I won't be he won't know to the
next episode to be continued Oh Vega
that was a good story
oh that pose though don't kill yourself
after seeing my dick please